ALEX BELLOS: These are the
English and American versions
of the same book, of
my book on numbers.
The English version, Alex's
Adventures in Numberland,
which was the first title
I came up with.
But then when we took it to the
American publishers, they
said, who's Alex?
Not going to work in America.
So we came up with another one,
which is kind of funnier,
Here's Looking at Euclid, which
when I then suggested to
the British publishers, they
said, well, who's Euclid?
So it actually works really
well for both different
territories.
Because in America, it
seems that everyone
has heard of Euclid.
And I'm not sure--
I'm never sure if this is
because Americans have better
geometry lessons or if it's
because Euclid appears a lot
more in street names and
city names in the US.
Actually, my theory is that the
reason why the Americans
name cities and streets after
Euclid is because the Founding
Fathers were Masons, and the
Masons were big into geometry.
I studied maths and philosophy
at university, but then I
became a journalist.
And then I ended
up as a foreign
correspondent in Brazil.
And so when I decided to write
about math, I decided to write
about math in the way
that a foreign
correspondent would write.
So I traveled all around the
world, interviewing different
people to do with numbers
and maths.
And it seemed to me that in a
sense, I was doing just what I
was doing as a foreign
correspondent, but I wasn't
going to any one country.
I was going to a kind of
fictitious country,
Numberland.
So in the same way that when I
was in Brazil, I would fly to
the Amazon and do a report, and
then explain it to people
who'd never been there.
In Numberland, I can fly to
the land of algebra or the
land of geometry, explain it,
come back, and give a report,
explain to people who don't
really understand the land of
algebra or geometry, and
explain how it is.
So I was also lucky that I've
had about 20 translations.
And I've got some of them here,
which has been done.
So we start here with Italian.
Il Meraviglioso Mondo
dei Numeri.
There are lots of
books around.
And there are lots of
books on numbers.
But I guess I felt there was a
gap in the market for a book
about numbers that was
accessible to the lay reader
in a way that other books
haven't been.
There have been books written
aimed at the lay reader, and
some of them should be
very successful.
But nothing really that's been
written by a news reporter.
Alex au Pays des Chiffres,
which is the French one.
Alex en el Pais de los
Numeros, which
is the Spanish one.
I hoped it would work.
I didn't know whether
it would.
I thought, maybe one of the
reasons why it hasn't been
done before is that it's
impossible to do.
But actually, using reportage
and journalism to write about
math, I think, works.
And I think I have brought
a new audience--
even if that audience is quite
small-- a new audience to
buying books about math.
And definitely if you read the
comments or the feedback about
the book, you do get lots of
people saying, oh my god, I've
never been interested in math
before, but I read this, and
it's quite interesting.
Kiehtova Matematikka, with a
little joke on the pi there,
which is Finnish.
Alex No Pais Dos Numeros,
from Brazil.
Always, when I'm writing, I'm
thinking, could the man on the
street read this?
Maybe a slightly educated
man on the street.
Because there are lots of people
who, you just put a
number in there and they don't
understand it at all.
But could someone who--
if you can read Freakonomics
and understand, if you can
read the financial pages of a
newspaper, if you've got GCSC
Maths, you should be able
to get quite a lot
out of what I write.
That's the aim.
Getallen Ontraadseld,
which is Dutch.
And that's the American, Here's
Looking at Euclid.
Pace is very difficult, because
you need to go slow
enough to take everyone with
you, but not so slow that
people who understand it
get a little bit bored.
So how did you do that?
You need to kind of sugar the
pill by including lots of
interesting color
and observation.
But you can't have too much of
that, because looks like it's
just filler.
Essentially, what you
need is you need a
really strong narrative.
You need people to want to know
what's going to happen.
And actually, my favorite
is the German
one, which is here--
Alex im Wunderland der Zahlen,
because it's got this
fantastic picture of me
kind of surfing an
abacus in my slippers.
I don't know which picture
they used, but--
BRADY HARAN: I've got you,
there, and let me zoom in on--
oh, yeah.
Yeah, that looks
a bit like you.
It is said that the minute you
put an equation in a piece of
text, you lose half
the readers.
I don't think that's true.
If you put it in--
if you build up the
equation and you
explain it well enough--
but still, you can't have
that many equations.
There's always going to be
more words than there are
numbers or equations per page.
And that can be quite difficult,
because maths
naturally has lots of number
and equations in it.
BRADY HARAN: Is your
book about numbers?
Or is your book about maths?
ALEX BELLOS: No, my book
is about maths.
And I started to write my book
about maths without having a
title for it.
And it was only halfway
through that
the title came up.
But even though it's a book
about maths, most people
think, well, maths and numbers
are the same thing.
So you know, the first 100 pages
of my book is really
about numbers-- the
birth of numbers.
Where did they come from?
Tribes that don't
have numbers.
Animals that understand
numbers.
Base systems, why we count up
to 10 and not 12, say, or 8.
So I think that numbers is
essentially where maths starts.
And in any book about maths,
you need to kind
of cover that area.
But actually, maths is about
structure, and pattern, and
logic, and proofs,
and elegance, and
all those other things.
And sometimes-- the thing with
numbers is that numbers in
themselves are actually
quite dry.
You need to use numbers to
explain other things.
BRADY HARAN: When you look back
and read the book now,
are there things you wish
you'd done differently?
Are there things you look at it
and go, I could have done
that better?
Or do you look at it and think,
I'm happy with that?
ALEX BELLOS: I think if you
ask most writers what they
think when they read their
books, they just cringe with
embarrassment.
So it's not so far in the past
that I don't look at it and
think, oh, I should have
done that a bit better.
That's not quite good enough.
But actually, in terms of
sales, and reviews, and
acclaim, I can't complain,
so I guess I must
be happy with it.